[Applause] turnover NCoin shoots big stop Primo
delivers early what a stop of the Bell Center
Baron got in the way as holla tried to accept
petta big hit on Eric Holla right at the Blue Line
and baron the other way drops petta Baron shoots
looking short side bazetta picks up the rebound
towards the N kick the side rebound score he did
it again Justin Baron Snipes and it's one nothing
Montreal bar strong start this play deep down in
the defensive Zone he makes the first good play
joins the rush I'd like the bad angle shot but
Michael petta all over this play starting with
a crushing hit in zone then a swing around
shot that catches B check off guard on the
bad angle rebound right out to Justin Baron
who pounds it home Andre Pat steers it up for
yesper brat brat on the Move he's got speed
left pass it front in the grease score as it
snuck through Kaden Primo a great feed in front
and ni heer slow to get up but he's made it a
1-1 game linesmen are all involved Ryan Daisy's
over offering an opinion as well this could be
interesting I think I think
they're going to take a look at
this and it looks like we get a decision
coming right now from Pier lamber reviewing
the play was determined there was go
[Music] interference so 32 of the 40
linesmen in the NHL are working tonight Brian
look out here comes brat Mat B brat on the
puck and there's an across shot w stop
Pat denied by Primo get serious what a
stop welcome back to the NHL and he is bringing
it for the Bell Center crowd on their feet early
here all five guys going back to him turn over
at the Blue Line a Nifty little pass from yesper
BR to the veteran Andre palot and watch the
right arm of Kaden Primo react coming across
a hard push and a bit of a dive and gets the
Blocker on that Justin Barrett finishing his
check near wall for Mercer him and Hamilton
play pass Mercer Hamilton One Time Bomb up
high on Primo rebound score Alexander Holtz
buries it in the late stages I don't know
if it's a power play goal regardless it is a 1-1
game as Holtz has his first of the year Teo Meer
actually gets his stick on this rebound douge
Hamilton shot from up top kovich not quite out
of the box it's the Meer knockdown of the puck
that puts it right on Alexander holtz's stick
and the talented young Swedish player knocks it
in on his backand but overall a strong start the
season for Kaden Primo his last NHL win he's
got three December 16 2021 it was at the Bell
Center versus the Flyers he made 37 stops and
he's getting his opportunity tonight it was a
3-2 victory that night here at the bellson pretty
incredible I guess either guy could handle dinner
depending on Whose City you're in but good for
both of them and Bright Futures of the NHL as
brat comes in Primo kicks it aside yes for brat
across Hamilton in shoots another good stop Primo
10 seconds left to the minor penalty Josh Anderson
with a bur of speed cutting in and he lost the
pluck Jack Hughes feads that right side that
shot off the post again is Marino labeled iron
behind Primo Jack Hughes assessing good
stick mat it comes to brat brat goes down
low in front he sure Jabs away off the post
still loose Primo is stretched right out and
he keeps it out as the Montreal Canadians
another great penalty kill Jacky again one
more time Harbor Jack guy Lindstrom waits
in front side of the net still loose and a
good poke check as it bounces around Monahan
was in tight vanage cheek lost his stick he
collects it Meer towards the net Luke Hughes
picks it up Luke Hughes flips it back in for
the Devils kova Savage takes Conta Hughes to
fley in shoot score the former half tier to
Foley Snipes and it's 2-1 New [Applause]
Jersey and that's Jack Hughes out by the
blue line that ends up in good position here to
make this this play the finish on the check in
tight pass comes across to Foley and he beats
Primo on the glove side just underneath and
that's a tough one to give up in the last minute
and a half of the period I would look to him to
have a strong third period last year Lindy
Ruffin this Devil's side franchise records
in wins and points yes for Brad and stride
picks it up circles around Brad of off for
luk Hughes yes for brat delivers to heer floats
it across Jack Hughes in front hands to Foley
followup Shri Primo down in front another
Drive score ni heser power play goal with
six seconds left of the minor and the Devils
little Insurance up 3-1 he sure knows to back
off the goal line not get too tight here and
give Hughes time to operate but it's Hughes on
the entry quick little pass over to BR and it
ends up on his stick down low watch him float
down below the goal line he picks it up here and
then is looking back across the front of the net
and then watch well you saw the relief in the
highlights for Alex ovka getting his first for
niiko Heir that's his first it's Josh Anderson
barreling in and driving play towards the goal
so it's a lot of pressure on your D for a
veteran like David card would be welcome in
this hockey game score right off the draw to fully
second of the game Power Play goal as the former
Montreal Canadian giving headaches to his former
squat three for four for New Jersey on the power
play pressure on Mike basson in the half boards
again the D stepping up so aggressively and just
popping that puck into the middle can see
to Foley in behind the D and anen in the
closest def Defender what a shot by Tyler
Chi for the Montreal Canadians as Kaden
Primo mat cutting it to the
for score what a goal Mike
[Music] [Applause] Mat it's not over yet Ryan I
spoke about how they were overplaying the drop
pass Jersey was very aggressive up Ice Mike
Madison is looking to drop this puck back and
everybody overplays the drop and he turns around
and says well if you're going to do that I'm going
the other way split Sean ther and John Marino
right down the new hook around the board Suzuki
picks it up for the half Suzuki with new hook
in front hu though on the puck drips it over
to Foley wide open net hatrick go TI her to F
he seals it his fifth career hattrick as the
New Jersey Devils will win one here at the Bell
Center on this Tuesday night Tyler choli missed
a couple times earlier but he wasn't missing that
one Nick Suzuki tries to come back to the point
somewhere between Gallagher and Matson is where
Jack Hughes picks it off the final touches for
the New Jersey Devils as they will beat the
Montreal Canadians what a game for Tyler to
fully the hattrick and what a performance for
from Jack Hughes his highend talent on display